au premier grand rendez vous que la
france s'en tirera avec le suffrage
universel soyez assurés que la situation
particulière de saint pierre et miquelon
sera prise en compte
l'archipel ne peut assumer son destin
qu'avec l'appui d'une france forte et
respectée capable de défendre
énergiquement ses droits avec le
concours de l'ensemble de la communauté
économique européenne
les habitants de saint pierre et
miquelon peuvent être assurés la totale
solidarité du rpr à l'égard d'un
département dont nous avons conscience
de l'isolément et dont nous voulons
combattre
l'appauvrissement ils en valent la
dignité de la france tout entière signé
jacques chirac ya cette crise traduit
bien les la fragilité finalement de tout
d'outre-mer française
saint-pierre-et-miquelon en particulier
alors quel avenir
quel avenir le rpr va pour
saint-pierre-et-miquelon là je veux
parler du statut
on parle actuellement on voit une
solution au changement de statut alors
qu'en pensez-vous rpr dont nous sommes
contre le changement de statut c'est
clair c'est net et celle ci et je pense
que départementalisation mesure telle
qu'elle est peut-être encore mieux
adaptés évidemment et qui colle un petit
peu mieux l'arrêter que nos départements
et département aménager un département
aménagé il faut pas oublier je voudrais
faire un petit peu d'historique les îles
de l'archipel de
saint-pierre-et-miquelon sont françaises
depuis 1600 4 elles ont toujours voté au
cours des scrutins et des consultations
électorales en faveur de l'intégration
avec l'ensemble françaises ont toujours
voulu rester celui par darcos est
toujours à kick score mais bien entendu
mais c'est important parce que il se
trouve que le département a été créée
sous l'impulsion de jacques chirac en
1976 qui à ce moment là était premier
ministre il était au gouvernement avec
monsieur ponette au ski avec monsieur
fourcade avec monsieur olivier stirn qui
à ce moment là était aux dom tom et nous
avons voulu faire
enfin le gouvernement à ce moment-là a
voulu que la population et les mêmes
droits les mêmes avantages législatifs
et réglementaires que n'importe quel
autre département métropolitain
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a voulu
faire bénéficier la population saint
pierre et miquelon de la solidarité
nationale et de leur intégration avec la
communauté économique européenne et huit
ans après on met ça en cause
pourquoi les résultats du département
sont extrêmement positifs dans leur
grande majorité les acquis la
départementalisation ils sont là pour
les ports l'ailé la voirie l'éclairage
les bâtiments publics les ptt le
satellite les télécommunications et tout
ça les acquis du département sont
fantastiques pourquoi est-ce qu'on il
faudrait les remettre en cause
maintenant donc la résumer un conclusion
pour la paire pas de changement de
statut souhaite a surtout pas de
changement de statut qui affaiblirait le
lien national et qui ne serait pas bon
pour saint-pierre-et-miquelon contraire
on éprouve une plus grande intégration
mais lorsque vous dites département
aménagé c'est pas un peu un territoire
en quelque sorte
non pas du tout pas du tout on peut très
bien rester dans le statut départemental
un petit peu mieux aménagés et qui tient
compte de la spécificité locale qui est
géographique qui est qu'il ya une petite
population et qui est le voisinage avec
nos amis canadiens
il ya une spécificité dont il faut tenir
compte indubitablement mais il faut
rester dans le statut départemental seul
garant de l'unité du pays